cat piss everdeen his back I bet no
one's called her that yet this is
original comedy the hunger games
catching fire this movie was on fire you
have got to watch this movie on imax
it's one of those imacs experiences
where you have like a mysterious
erection for like two hours not because
you're horny but because you're
impressed just like holy wow [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry I know I'm swearing a lot today
but [ __ ] when a movie is this awesome
you just can't find the right words to
describe the emotion that you feel you
know where I live up to the experience
so you see [ __ ] like man it was [ __ ]
bomb dude [ __ ] [ __ ] fun let me first
start off by saying this maybe there's
one hell of a truly cinematic experience
it's a science fiction movie yet it's
like grounded in reality that feels
really human at the same time and
there's great action great adventure
just the world of imagination like
Disneyland where I got soup for punching
a five-year-old in the face it's a dark
film like a really dark film it's like
the reverse transition of Michael
Jackson it's fast-paced much faster pace
in the first Hunger Games and it was
shot differently to the first one was
very handheld to go for that realistic
thing which totally works for the first
one but for this story I did prefer the
motion of this camera instead what I
will say in comparison to the first one
is it doesn't feel as dangerous as the
first one like it's not as scary because
of the first Hunger Games it's just kids
slaughtering each other and they kill a
little black girl [ __ ] racist can't
believe no one's pointed that out yet
about the first Hunger Games how racist
that was not one person mentioned in
this hunger games is more dealing with
like natural disasters attack sins and
stuff like that because they're just out
to get Katniss the whole time sorry
kappas that's what I mean though they
took the original world of the Hunger
Games stay true to it then continue the
story from where we left off if you've
seen the first on your games you'll
probably love this movie if you haven't
seen the first Hunger Games you'll
appreciate it it's kind of like being
friends with a factor you know she's
nice but I wouldn't [ __ ] her messing
with you fat chicks is my thing that's
all I good and everything in this one is
like the effect
what happened from the first one to me
it's just one of the best sequels ever
Jennifer Lawrence is [ __ ] awesome in
this film she commands the scream I
liked her in the first Hunger Games but
man was I blown away by her performance
blown away sexual reference she's to go
much deeper has to do so much darker
emotions she really gets a shot that
Oscar talent she has if Jennifer
Lawrence and I were friends I would have
so much sex with her no but seriously
she anchors this film I just felt like
she understood the character even way
more I feel like she read the book and
josh hutcherson still can't figure out
this guy's name things like pita bread
or something with it but this dude's a
delight to watch I think he's really
[ __ ] cool you know like his acting is
actually really good does the character
it has a lot of internal struggles and
he doesn't get enough credit for his
performance he's not just like the nice
guy you really care for him even
Jennifer Lawrence work well together and
Liam Hemsworth you know Thor's brother
but he'll forever be known as and for
hit him out his pase I love philip
seymour hoffman anything this guy does I
think he's entertaining to watch he like
plays up the villain role a little bit
almost mustache twirling but he doesn't
in just enough well you know just to
write him out of energy and Donald
Sutherland he has like two scenes in the
first Hunger Games then the whole time
he's just like watering his garden he
could have hired mexicans to do that for
him but no he's a racist and he doesn't
want Mexicans on his property we get
Donald so totally he's like the
antagonist of this film and he does a
really really good job it's almost like
he's not acting I don't mean that in a
bad way he's just like so relaxed in
front of the camera and him and philip
seymour often were fantastic together
the visual effects are awesome the
production design art design costume
design all fantastic it's funny because
this one was like grounded in reality
but yet it's like a visual feast the
entire time the writing of this was
top-notch the story just gets bigger and
bigger as it goes along there's reveal
surprises and everything just unfolds in
a smart way it's kind of scary to it's a
different kind of scary than the first
one but this time around like everyone's
ass out to kill Katniss and the score is
so [ __ ] good a lot of people were
worried when they heard they were
switching directors in the first one but
whoever
this done was then did a great [ __ ]
job he knew how to capture the tone of
the first film yet add even more to it I
loved it more than the first one let me
get straight to the point here all i
gotta say the hunger games catching fire
got it super right all right guys dick
chicken on my review for the hungry
games catching fire watch it go head
skull that comment box below and tell me
what would you do on a date with
jennifer lawrence i just want to go
ahead and follow me on twitter BAM do
real ryan right that's my name someone
else is called ryan right I'm gonna
fight you [ __ ] anyone see more
in-depth review of the hunger games
catching fire go ahead and check out my
show called reasons to see that do my
buddy Jared we got hot model on the show
and Caroline Mitchell Wow right last
Mona Lisa go and get updated every time
one of my reviews this out kotick look
at this butter by my dick to subscribe
that's right the dick I got to tell you
something this little Ryan he's hungry
and he's willing to play all kinds of
games he'll set your [ __ ] on fire not
because I have gonorrhea